in this video i'll break down the golden
fishing rod and animal crossing new
horizons
i'll explain how to get it how long you
have to wait what it does and most
importantly
is it worth it people of the internet
retrorecontour here and welcome to
another animal crossing new horizons
video
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and today we're talking all
about the golden fishing rod and animal
crossing new horizons
so there's actually two ways to get a
golden fishing rod one way is really
easy and the other
way takes a lot more time but will
ultimately be better for you in the long
run
the easy way is through gifting or
trading that's right you can have a
friend who's already
unlocked the goldenrod send one straight
to your mailbox
alternatively you could also trade for
one through some of the animal crossing
discord groups such as nukazon
there are some significant downsides to
this however you see if you're just
gifted the item you won't actually
receive the recipe which means when your
goldenrod eventually breaks
and yes they really do break but more on
that in a second but when it does break
you won't be able to make another to
replace it so you'd be right back to
where you started
that being said there is another
downside to receiving golden tools as
gifts
first you won't actually be working for
and earning the goldenrod how the game
intended
don't get me wrong i'm glad the gifting
option is there especially for younger
kids who may not be able to play during
the hours required to actually unlock
the rod
in game but i actually had someone gift
me a golden axe without me
even asking might i had and while it was
an awesome gift it definitely took that
sense of achievement away from
actually earning the reward so if you
only want the golden fishing rod then by
all means trade for it find a friend
who'll give it to you
but if you want that sense of
achievement then you'll want to stay
tuned maybe it's just me who knows but i
actually
love working towards in-game goals this
is absolutely one of those things that's
entirely
up to you though okay so how do you
unlock it for
real the second way of unlocking the
goldenrod and what most would say is the
true way of doing it
you have to catch every fish in the game
that's right
every single fish now that we're right
around the one year mark of animal
crossings launched that means that both
northern and southern hemisphere players
have now had a chance to catch
every fish in the game without time
travel
one important note here regarding the
golden rod is that you do not have to
turn the fish into the museum
personally i always turn my first catch
of each fish into the museum anyway but
if you're someone who doesn't bother
with the museum then
what's wrong with you i'm kidding i'm
kidding regardless
turning a fish into the museum is not a
requirement you just have to make sure
that each fish shows up in your critter
pedia
using the critter pedia makes it very
easy to check and see how many fish you
still need
from there i'd recommend using the
animal crossing wiki page or a mobile
app such as
acnh.guide seriously awesome app
check it out if you're new to the game
you should know that fish change with
both the time of day
and the current month of your island
there are even certain fish that can
only be caught when it's raining or
from the pier on your island all of this
information for each fish can be found
on those sites i mentioned
i'll be sure and link them in the
description as well important note here
you do not need to catch
all of the deep sea creatures in order
to receive the golden rod it's fish
only for this one once you catch your
final fish though
well you'll receive a fun little message
in game which i won't spoil here but for
me
after that it was a little unclear how i
actually
get the golden rod and even digging
around online i couldn't really find an
exact answer to what i was looking for
it's part of the reason i made this
video here
once you catch all the fish what do you
do from there luckily the solution is
rather simple for me i just needed to
wait until the next day and then
inside my mailbox i found this special
letter from the faraway museum
again you still don't have to turn the
fish into the museum they congratulated
me on catching every fish and inside
was the recipe for the golden fishing
rod from there go to your nearest
crafting bench and you can immediately
craft the rod which requires one
standard fishing rod and one gold nugget
to craft
so there you have it your reward for
catching every fish in the game is the
golden
fishing rod but is it really worth all
that time invested
there's pros and cons here on the
positive side you have a specially
colored tool that shows just how much of
a dedicated fisherman you are
and golden tools are the most durable in
the game however they actually do have a
set lifespan and will eventually break
they do last quite a long time and my
goldenrod has yet to break i can't say
for certain but i've seen reports online
that you can get as many as
200 uses out of the golden tools if any
of you out there know the exact amount
let everyone know down in the comments
below i'd love to know if there's been
an
actual number confirmed for how many
times you can use the golden fishing rod
for me i wish the golden tools were
unbreakable but i certainly don't regret
going for it the truth is i would have
wanted to catch all the fish
anyway even if it was just a check mark
in my nook app so i just see the golden
rod as kind of like a visual indicator
of the achievement that i completed
if you're new to animal crossing new
horizons i have a full beginners
playlist here on the right side of the
screen
as always thank you guys so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon